Nộng Hoa Minh, tên tiếng Anh là Månh Myss là một cơ trế cúc tên mới, giò tổng thống mính đường nó trăm hợi sướng.
Đó để bộ Việt Nam rất đau là phó thủ tưởng vụ thân sơn, là dự lệ kiến chương của họ đồng này về chấm rất xung lột tại giải gà ra.
Thao lệ mời của tổng thống đường nó trăm.
Lệ ki ý với được tổ chức ngày hông qua, bên lệ dễ dễ đạt kinh tế thế giới tại NaVost PICI.
Tổng thống đường nó trăm sẽ là chủ tịch nấu tiên của họ đồng Hoa Minh, Bónh PICI.
Con chấm rất xung lột tại giải gà ra sẽ chỉ là những vụ bà đầu.
Sau đó thì một bíu dài hơi của họ đồng Hoa Minh là tạo ra một cơ trế cúc tên mới,
thúc này Hoa Minh ổn định và dài quyết các xung lột trên thế giới.
Đi tưởng thân là phó thủ tổng thống đường này, được tổng thống đường nó trăm, nề xuất từ thẳng chiến năm ngoái,
trong khun khổ, kế hoa chấm rất xung lột tại giải gà ra.
Sau đó, thường trăm muốn vặt độc đồng này sẽ đất mở gió đa phạm viên quan cầu.
Đi tưởng thống đồng Hoa Minh, lông dài, những khu vực bị xung lột, khoảng là cóu ý cơ xung lột.
Hồi đồng này được ra mắt tại NaVoz, rựa lúc những căng thẳng về chính trị và con xúc trên tổng thống,
vẫn đang tức tạm. Vì thế vai cho và anh vường của Hội đồng Hoa Minh,
đang là chủ đề nhất được nhiều sự quan tâm.
Các khu khó khó thành viên của Hội đồng Hoa Minh có thể sẽ chỉ được thăm ra với những kỳ là 3 năm,
chứ khi, nóng hoa một tỉ đồ là Mỹ để tài trở cho hạc đồng của Hội đồng
và đổi lấy tức cách là quốc gia thành viên thường dật.
Hồ đồng Hoa Minh đã quốc tháng 1,5 năm ngoài cũng đã cho phép thành là quốc đồng Hoa Minh tập trung dài
của xung lột đồng gà ra và hạc đồng. Tới năm sau, anh y hủ trăm 2 bẩy.
Trong đó, thì liên là quốc cũng cho phép khổ đồng này được chiến 2 một lực lượng quốc tế
rí trì ông nịch tạm thời gà ra. Hồ đồng Hoa Minh cũng sẽ phải mạo gạo tiến bộ cho hộ đồng
Hoa Minh đã quốc sấu tháng 1 lần.
Và cho tới nay thì ít nhất mà mà làm cú ra đã cảm kết thăm ra hộ đồng Hoa Minh tính trong tổng số khoảng
năm môi lời mới đã được ở đi.